Bộ Môn Linh Côn Mô Bài, tại đấu đấu chiến dậy phọt mô đồng hay ngàn phân chăm ha mấy lâm,
năng bước vào về đạn sôi động nhất.
Thì trong tuần vừa qua, như hôm mộ đã được chiến loạt trận tịch tính,
này cảm sốt.
Những ông lớn của là nghĩ của Việt Nam,
nên thực chặp chắn, phật công hiện, những mặt sợ tài mạnh nhắn.
1. Sợi sô có thực tục hàng định vì thế ứng cử viên vô định,
khi giữ chỉ mặt bất bà, túng vàn ở môi đồ bàn.
Cái phía sau, Team Flas chờ lại mạnh mẽ với những chiến hàng liên tiết,
trong đó, nổ bàn nhất là màn hạ gục xài gòn phân tâm ở trạng xíu kinh điện
với tì số 3, 2, 3, 2, 3, đe kịch tính.
Tất cả này, khiến xài gòn phân tâm tạm thời gian xôi xống vị trí thứ 3,
đánh mất lợi thế trong cuộc đua tốt đầu.
Bóbs game main cũng cho thấy phòng độ ẩn thượng,
khi lên tục diao xấu cho tìt game main và giữa đevo Team,
qua đó giữa trác một chủ trong nhỏ mạnh chàng về play,
supranova, giù có hợi đồ không thể,
nhưng vẫn chưa đủ ordn力 tạm đứng ở nửa giới bản sẽ khác.
Trong khi đó, giờ đevo Team và FT vẫn đang loại hoài team hướng đi,
còn tìt game main giới vào khủng hoạt khi chưa thể team thấy chiến hàng,
chấp nhận đứng quế bản sau tình khi đấu này.